I
with the main parties looking as though
they're fighting each other to a
standstill in the national campaign you
need to keep a close eye on the action
at constituency level local issues
candidates local tussles that will shape
the overall picture seat by seat
inverness nan bay de NOC and strafes pay
what a mouthful and water battle echoes
of the independence referendum hear the
signs breeding all over the place now
activists crisscrossing the constituency
SNP troops sensing a real prize the
scalp of a high-profile lib dem
incumbent Danny Alexander the Liberal
Democrat foot soldiers are just as
resolute still believing the back of
their nationalist opponents may be worse
than their bite with the rival shades of
yellow so dominant in this Highland seat
other parties are likely to trail some
way behind polling suggests the
landscape is shifting decisively the
Nationalists way but not everyone is
willing to be open at this stage can
i'll see you a very quick question about
the general election go second runner
Isom thank you I season carlile see no
sorry and even some who would talk kept
their cards close to their chests and
whose swaying you at the moment I'd
rather keep that to myself in my front
door of the minute what do you mind
telling me yes to do right okay I'm not
going to go first what this nationalist
definitely not definitely not so that
means what it's got to be Danny
Alexander then here if you is that right
yeah nicola sturgeon
on yourself
simcha I think people's minds have been
changed because in Scotland we haven't
been given the extra Paris that we've
been promised and I think a lot of
people who didn't vote no reverted nor
for the referendum have been very
disappointed either UK for SMP right
same as me as well but not two parties
that most people would put together I
think SNP's like raw like yay Scotland I
thank the necklace Sturgeon has really
changing the way she talks and
everything she's always really
articulate so you how you are fans of
Nicola Sturgeon and Nigel Farage she's a
fun at major photos how does that work
you must be the only girl no I don't
like him I think he's you know but like
I like his policies unlike immigration
like saving any chance like I think he's
I think he's talking sense so my game so
what about a yay for Danny Alexander
then he's got a good job all right love
but my votes not gone for not sure
that's going to be much consolation for
I know but cheers anyway this may indeed
be a bridge too far for the lib dems
though don't forget past experience in
Scotland shows nationalists tend to be
more open with their views before
polling day in any case this is a
general election the like of which
Scotland has never before experienced
and it's bound to have a momentous
impact north and south of the border